نعم هو مستمر قبل دقائق اعلن حزب الله عن
هجوم خامس
في على موقع جل العلام الاسرائيلي في
القطاع الغربي ليصبح عدد الهجمات لهذا
اليوم خمسه هجمات حزب الله يستهدف تجمعات
الجنود وايضا تحركاتهم ويرصد حركتهم
باستمرار ويطلق الصواريخ والاسلحه
المناسبه باتجاه هذه التجمعات في محاوله ل
اكبر قدر ممكن من الخسائر بشريه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهو ما شاهدناه ايضا يوم امس
حين قام حزب الله بشن سلسله عمليات مشابهه
على تجمعات للجنود وتحركاتهم وانتشارهم
واستخدام الاسلحه المناسبه حتى ان في احدى
الاستهدافات استخدم طائره مسيره في منطقه
وقرب موقع رميم وبعد ان اخلى الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذه السكنه باتجاه ال الغابات
القريبه منه فاستهدف حزب الله بمسيره مما
ادى الى مقتل وجرح عدد من الاشخاص هناف
وفقا لبيان حزب الله بعد ان تمكنت هذه
الطائره المسيره من اختراق الدفاعات
الجويه الاسرائيليه اثر اطلاق حزب الله
صواريخ ضللت هذه ال الدفاعات الجويه
وتمكنت المسيره من الوصول الى اهدافها لكن
الجانب الاسرائيلي استمر في عمليات القصف
هذا اليوم ايه ثلاث غارات من مسيرات
اسرائيليه على يارون مارون الراس وايضا
على بلده الطيبي القريبه من الحدود
اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه حزب الله استهدف
عدد الجانب الاسرائيلي استهدف عدد من
الاهداف في هذه المنطقه واستمر بعمليات
القصف المدفعي التي شملت على الاقل محيط
واطراف خمس بلدات لبنانيه وقبل قليل قصفت
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه منطقه او محيط منطقه
اللبونه وهي التي تقع في القطاع الغربي
المسيرات الاسرائيليه في هذه اللحظه تحلق
في اجواء القطاع الشرقي وتحديدا فوق مناطق
ف فرشو
وتلال وشبعه وايضا تحاول المسيرات
المراقبه الحثيثه على الارض لتحركات حزب
الله كانت امس شهدت ايضا منطقه حومين وهي
تقع خارج منطقه عمليات اليونيفل وتحديدا
خارج منطقه العمليات العسكريه المعتاده
بين حزب الله والجانب الاسرائيلي وشنت
مسيره هجوم على منزلا في هذه المنطقه التي
تبعد على الاقل 40 ك عن الحدود ودمرت
منزلا دون ان يسجل اي اصابات في صفوف من
كانوا فيه حزب الله يعتبر بشكل رسمي بان
ما جرى ويجري من تصريحات اسرائيليه خلال
الفتره الاخيره هو بمثابه تهديدات و يعتبر
وفق ما جاء على لسان الشيخ نبيل قوق وهو
احد قياديه وعضو اللجنه المركزيه يقول ف
بان لو كانت اسرائيل قادره لكانت نفذه وان
الردع من جانب حزب الله قوي ومتماسك شكرا
ايهاب العقده من مرجعيون في جنوبي لبنان